well let's get more now on that and
joining me is former conservative party
chairman and Rishi sunak supporter
Oliver Dowden good afternoon to you uh
uh families watching us today are facing
up to 1600 pounds a year loss so a a
quarter of their income going towards
energy bills potentially and here we
have two potential leaders not able to
agree on how to deal with the financial
crisis
well I think you're and good afternoon I
think you're absolutely right to
highlight the scale of the challenge
being faced and this is my concern if
this is purely done by bringing forward
these national insurance tax cuts for
somebody who's working for example
full-time on the national living wage
that will benefit them by less than 60
pounds whereas whoever's new prime
minister will benefit that person by up
to 1 800 pounds so these measures are
not fit to deal with the scale of the
challenge that we are facing
so clearly you're saying that Liz
truss's measures are not suitable and
your favorite candidate Richie sunax are
but the the points I'm trying to make is
people watching this are are likely to
be and many people I'm speaking to are
pretty bemused because there's such a
different uh approach and we've got a
prime minister and a chancellor of
exchequer who are away on holiday is
anything being done behind the scenes to
try and help people right now
well yes and uh you may remember that uh
when Rishi sunap was Chancellor the
exchequer alongside uh prime minister
Boris Johnson they announced a wide
range of measures to support people and
in particular the most vulnerable people
will get up to 1 200 pounds and it
really is that kind of direct support
that is required to help people at this
very difficult time and merely uh
promising to bring forward a national
insurance card will not be sufficient in
the scale if you think about somebody on
that lowest income uh working full-time
the national living wage 60 pounds isn't
enough it requires those kind of big
bold interventions which you saw from
Rishi sunaxis
well I think you've seen already a very
bold response from when uh Richie sunak
was Chancellor of the exchequer he
committed to uh 1 200 pounds the most
vulnerable and he's been clear that
he'll be willing to take further action
as required and by the way that that
also does include tax cuts that's why
he's committed to removing VAT on
domestic fuel but it's quite clear when
one looks at the scale of what people
are facing the bigger and Bolder action
will be required
do you think uh Rishi sunak is able to
actually catch up with uh Liz trust now
uh yes I do and I think what we saw from
the warnings from the bank of England uh
at the end of last week was the scale of
the challenge facing any incoming prime
minister and I think set against that
challenge you want someone with the
drive and the experience to deal with
this kind of economic crisis that's
exactly what Rishi sunak showed when he
dealt with the covert crisis you
remember we were facing a situation
where Millions if not tens of millions
of people could have lost their jobs at
the height of covert because of lockdown
measures he brought in that job
retention scheme the furlough scheme
saving millions of jobs is that kind of
bold action that is required and the
experience and that's why I'm backing
Rishi sunak because I believe he brings
both of those things to the table
the times is referring to the Great
British pledge off I mean both
candidates have made you know
extraordinary number of pledges are they
actually going to hold to that because
those seem to be pledges that are
playing to their current very small
audience rather than the wider
electorate
well actually I would argue and I I
think you've seen that Richie suneck has
taken some Flack for not promising large
tax cuts funded by borrowing because he
recognizes and indeed I recognize that
the biggest problem we face right now as
a nation is inflation and we have to
come down on that scourge of inflation
and it was interesting to me that Nigel
Lawson that most successful of
chancellors under Margaret Thatcher
endorsed Rishi sunak's proposals
precisely because he's willing to take
the difficult decisions to control
inflation because if we don't control
inflation it makes everyone poorer and
when inflation is running at 13 in a few
short years people can see their savings
their pensions income their their income
from work halved it is a really
pernicious thing that level inflation we
have to take the tough action now to
deal with it but also to help people in
the short term through this difficult
period which is why you saw the sort of
measures that Rishi has already
announced quite but Gordon Brown calling
it a financial Time Bomb is is no uh
small thing is it uh and finally you
know given that we've got these two
candidates with such differing views and
a level of backing from both uh from
across the party and the members what
happens when one of them becomes leader
is the government going to be singing
from the same hymn sheet or are we going
to see more disarray and chaos
no I think both sides will come together
in the National interest and I think
actually Gordon Brown's comments rather
illustrate this we all remember what
Gordon Brown did when faced with a
situation like this the poultry 75p
increase in the state pension it's
exactly that sort of thing that will
come together to resist and I'm
confident that we have two good
candidates to lead our country but I'm
also clear that Rishi sunax proposals
are up to the scale of the challenge
that we face and we have to get real as
a as a Nation about the scale of the
challenges we face and the leadership
that's required through it we're gonna
have to leave it there Oliver Darden
thanks very much indeed thank you